معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850 كم
شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف وخمسمائه
مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه شاحنه بات
يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من اشتباكات السودان
عبر منه الالاف من السودانيين والمصريين
هربا من القتال بعد اجتياز المعبر يتجه
المسافرون الى مدينه اسوان الوصول اليه
يتطلب رحله محفوفه بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف
يوم للوصول اليه من الخرطوم ومده مماثله
للعبور الى اسوان ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في
السودان سمح للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره
مسبقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات